let's talk about this first big story
this is crazy
from al jazeera trudeau lifts emergency
order invoked to end trucker protests
amid criticism the canadian pm insists
emergencies act was needed to quell
anti-government blockades and occupation
speaking to reporters on wednesday
afternoon trudeau said the emergencies
act was necessary to help law
enforcement agencies disperse large
numbers of protesters who had descended
on ottawa we get it but it's not true
it's absolutely not true they could have
had a very small group of police
officers very small
walk up to the peaceful truckers and say
we're placing you under arrest for you
know obstructing a roadway and that's it
we've seen them do this over and over
again to climate change activists to
lifting protesters i understand canada
is a different country than the u.s but
come on policing is very similar here
and there instead they pulled out the
boot and they put it on people's necks
my opinion is that they wanted to make
these emergency powers permanent we
already heard the deputy prime minister
in canada say we want this this you know
financial powers to be permanent because
of cryptocurrencies and and crowdfunding
and now all of a sudden oh we're lifting
the order why i think the backlash was
bad they they wanted to use the protest
as an excuse to expand their powers it
didn't work
well i don't know what's going to happen
next
certainly they did crush those protests
we got protests coming here into the u.s
they're trying to unfreeze bank accounts
but i'll throw it to you guys i mean you
you guys have been on the ground for a
lot of protests i don't know if you guys
were following what was happening with
the truckers up in canada or you know
similar protests but i'm curious what
your thoughts are based on what you've
seen on the ground versus what's
displayed in the news i think for me the
biggest takeaway was this is one of the
biggest uh worker uprisings that we've
ever seen in our history where you
actually have true
you know people in the middle class
working class actually up rising
together and it's not like a fringe left
or fringe right um it's just a true
working class coming together then you
actually got to see the canadian
government how they responded with just
complete government overreach using
their security forces to beat up on
protesters to beat up on also members of
the media a lot of members of the rebel
news which i'm really truly grateful for
for rebel news because their journalists
have been on the ground and just getting
us these crucial videos um of what's
going on in ottawa and without them i
feel like we would be just kind of be um
you know depending on the corporate
media and the way actually i look at
rebel news is actually i look at um our
dc riot squad in 2020 where it's like
you kind of have these few on the ground
reporters getting these kind of viral
videos and showing you the truth um but
i think one of the biggest takeaways
from what's going on in canada was that
you know governments all over
have been completely silent when it
comes to violence on peaceful protesters
and also members of the media um i think
one of the key takeaways that i've took
away is that at least the president of
el salvador naibu kelly has come out and
spoken out against this and it's it's
it's interesting to see because for me
as well as you know if these
demonstrations were happening in you
know in yemen or afghanistan or anything
like that the us government will be
quickly you know up in arms and telling
us how we need to intervene but since
it's canada i mean we've been completely
silent on this issue didn't didn't uh
canada issue a statement about cuba
recently like during the protest did you
see that something like that where
they're like people should have their
free speech like shut up nobody believes
you you know what's really fascinating
about this though
the craziest thing is for me to see you
mention this in the intro that garcetti
is like bang your pots and pans for the
first responders and i'm like you mean
be a public nuisance and keep people up
at night no no i i don't really care
about the the pots and pans what are
what what do they call that they call it
the casseroles products
yeah i don't mind that i don't care if
people are banging pots and pans i'll go
and be like make some noise but they
complain about the truckers honking
their horns
now i get it i'll say it all the time
different countries
but the same people in the u.s who are
supporting banging pots and pans and
protesting with black lives matter
during a pandemic are condemning
truckers for going out and protesting
speaking of like protests uh the trucker
protest is like a perfect example of
what a peaceful demonstration looks like
and
the whole cause and effect is just to
cause a disruption so that people in
charge realize that
though like we are essential to what you
do and how the country works and if we
stop working there's a huge problem
so you as our ruler are kind of
responsible to take care of what are our
needs and the answers because like you
are in charge of us well and we vote you
we watch you guys in i take my cues from
alexandria ocasio-cortez she's a great
leader
is right the problem is the protests she
was defending were violent
riotous
and
the ones we're defending are like people
parking their trucks in the street and
honking
i wonder if they would have had a better
protest if they weren't honking if they
had just blocked traffic and sat there
and stopped working because like you
want to make people uncomfortable but
it's the kind of discomfort we're like
uh oh if the truckers aren't there we're
gonna suffer not the kind of discomfort
we're like it hurts because you're
making so much noise stop because now
most of those people in ottawa wanted
the truckers they're downtown though
it's not like they're going into suburbs
and like residential neighborhoods worse
downtown because you have buildings with
just densely packed uh citizens that are
suffering basically it's not a
residential area though
i've seen a video of people like in
their high rises recording from above
they're people who live there i'm not
saying nobody lives there but it's not
like they're going into a strictly
residential neighborhood they're going
into like downtown i understand the
intent to disrupt and blockade and just
and to i get that part but it's the
noises was really destructive probably
unnecessarily destructive so so american
guys you truckers keep that in mind
they're looking for a reason to bust you
don't give them oh everyone's posting
one's in chat no no no no no
honking
honking i think is brilliant me too uh
it's it's it's you're just honking your
horn you're making noise these
protesters go around with boom boxes
they go around screaming they go around
chanting they bang drums non-stop this
is what protests have have been doing
for a really really long time to come
out now and be like oh but the truckers
shouldn't i'm like
look we tolerate a certain degree of of
discomfort for for non-violent civil
disobedience and making noise can be
annoying and frustrating but it really
does show you the the the complete bs
that is the left right paradigm that
when you are making noise in their city
how dare you oh i'm gonna go and enact
emergency powers and freeze your banks
yet they they can go out and they can
bang whatever they want whatever they
want for their cause that when you're
when you're engaging in your protest on
the steps of your state capitol building
they say oh it's a super spreader event
these these evil far-right guys and then
they go up by the thousands during the
same pandemic and the nurses are
clapping and cheering from i love that
photo where the nurse is standing in
front of the truck that says like no
mandates or whatever and they're like
you know
hands on their hips and then at the same
time you get a video of nurses clapping
for black lives matter i'm like dude i'm
not playing this stupid you get you know
rules for thee but not for me game if if
if we tolerate
banging from the left and pots and pans
i got no issue with people honking i
wouldn't tolerate it outside my house if
people were making noise 24 7. i
wouldn't tolerate it i'd make it stop
and if the law wasn't well there's lots
of ways to do it no there isn't yeah one
of them is called the cops
right and then noise ordinances and
stuff for a reason so you support the
the emergency powers to crack down and i
think they could the fact that they
could do that and do it again tomorrow
if they wanted to spin them up again is
terrifying and we should repeal the
patriot act that they could use the in
the nda
i mean for me it's hard to fault the
truckers at all i mean the honking's not
a big deal i guess for me from my
perspective is just from being on the
ground and seeing the black lives matter
protests in person you know you had
folks in i mean there was a famous
aerial shot in dc where almost it looked
like every single building was on fire
you had people in dc and their high
races where they're filming videos like
actually cheer on the protest and as
soon as the protesters look at them
they'll like throw a rock through the
window so for me it's like you know the
honking i can't fault um especially what
we've seen on the ground here in the
united states and the thing is the media
that's demonizing the truckers i mean
they're all in cities that were being
wrecked by the black lives matter
protests in in 2020 yeah so i may
disagree with ian about um whether or
not the trucker should have been honking
but i do think he has a salient point
about the feds now keeping a very close
eye on the truckers jack pacobic also
made the point recently he said i don't
think that a convey is the best way to
get your point across he said i think
that a general strike is a better way to
do it yeah and i think that's true
because it is so decentralized there's
something we talk a lot about i think
something so decentralized would really
drive the point home look at this video
real quick such a great video look at
this video
from the black lives matter insurrection
in washington dc look at the smoke
everywhere
it's it's it's absolutely insane i i
would never forget that image i remember
that image always yeah that always
sticks out my sister she owns a wine bar
downtown dc and the day after this she
sent me photos of her glasses and she
has like plants outside the bar and
everything was shattered and stuff like
that and even if like i was to like step
myself out of the bubble and be like hey
is this dangerous or are truckers
blocking downtown and honking dangerous
i would rather i don't know i would
choose the one where my sister's bar
glasses got shattered
right right right we're going to see
this freedom convoy there's two there's
the people there's there's actually
several there's more than two people's
convoy is going to be leaving i think
they left today they left today from um
are lonzo california yeah which is in
san bernardino and and they're planning
on making it to dc by the fifth yeah
yeah but there's also the freedom small
ones yeah yeah it's crazy and they're
gonna be there on the first so i guess
they're driving a lot more so basically
starting march there's gonna be like a
lot of truckers a lot of people
basically all over the dmv area
we're super close to frederick which is
like the last and it's not just that now
dc is again back to
the green zone which it was after jan 6
which is kind of makes me really sad
because i've been living in dc for like
three years now and the city was all
fine and dandy
before i don't know like covet and after
covet happened and john 6 happened the
city turned into a green zone and it was
all sad and gloomy and downtown you can
like hear like a needle drop
and it was kind of getting better and
starting i don't know like yesterday
it's again like getting locked up and
yeah that it feels like a symbolic
protest this this going to dc and
setting up in the capital like it's it's
more it's not a functional protest that
doesn't actually do anything you're
you're wrong it's just wrong it's like
look how look at how big i am
i'm bigger than you i control the world
now and the feds are going to be like no
you don't bro and i'm going to show you
how you don't thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time